welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast I'm Gus Docker I'm here with
Nathan lebens Nathan is doing research
and development at waymark into AI video
creation and he also co-hosts the
cognitive Revolution podcast which I
really recommend by the way Nathan
welcome to the podcast thank you very
much Gus I'm excited for this okay so
why the name cognitive Revolution how do
you think about that concept what what
is what is happening in the world that
that will would make you name your
podcast cognitive Revolution well it
seems like we're hitting a moment of you
know with kind of apologies to you know
Karl Marx uh it seems like we're hitting
a moment where we're about to enter a
change in the quote unquote mode of
production uh that's kind of how I came
to that notion you know the the way we
do things seems like it is about to
fundamentally change at a minimum you
know and we can speculate about a lot
more change that might be in store for
us as well but you know I was just kind
of looking back into history and trying
to think like what are the kind of right
reference points for a change of this
magnitude and you know people are all
everybody's kind of groping around
trying to find the right analogy or the
right comparison right now and I kind of
kept looking a little bit farther and
farther back where I was like is it you
know the iPhone no I think it's bigger
than the iPhone actually is it like the
internet better but I would still say
like it's it seems like it might even be
bigger than that
and kind of work my way back to like the
Industrial Revolution and that's kind of
you know where I stopped and I said yeah
it feels like this is kind of the right
comparison because
if you go back you know to the
pre-industrial revolution then you know
look at that change
generally speaking like we used to do
everything with our muscles
and then we sort of figured out that
like we could get machines to do that
stuff for us and it kind of changed
everything and the life you know Bears
you know some resemblance but is also
Way Beyond what anyone could have
imagined before that transition got
underway
and that's kind of what I think we're
headed into now you know we we currently
use machines to do the stuff that we
used to do with our muscles but we still
use our brains you know largely to do
the stuff that we do with our brains and
you know
computers have chipped away at that in
some areas but nothing like what I think
we're about to start to see so really
more than anything just trying to drive
home uh for people that this is I think
bigger than anything we've lived through
and you kind of have to go pretty far
back in history to find something
comparable and if this is indeed the
right historical analogy then we're in
store for something massive the
Industrial Revolution is in many ways a
singular moment in history in which we
we see that a mass escape from poverty
we see in in very uh very steep rises in
living standards in many countries and
so on is is that how you also
think about the revolution we're about
to undergo do you think we will see
higher growth better living standards
massive technological innovation yes uh
I certainly hope so and but I don't
think it's like a given you know there's
kind of two big complications to that
story and I'm very
bullish on AI technology in general and
just like excited about it you know in
my daily work like I love working with
it I love what it can do for me
um so that's one of the reasons also I
wanted to to do you know a podcast is
kind of to communicate both sides of
this because I I do have the enthusiasm
and the optimism you know for a scenario
like what you outlined there
and then at the same time I'm also like
boy
it sure seems like we don't have a great
handle on this technology yet it seems
qualitatively different in some ways
from like the rise of industrial
machines
and you know who knows what might happen
with that
um and then I also think too there's
potentially a lot of pain or at a
minimum like disruption between here and
there I mean you go back to the history
of the Industrial Revolution first of
all it took a lot longer kind of a
multi-generation time frame from like
when they first started using you know
very rudimentary and kind of handcrafted
Pistons to like pump water out of Wells
so they could keep digging coal deeper
you know beyond where it would flood
um doing that at the mine site you know
from that moment to like a quality steam
engine you're talking like probably
three generations of people refining the
technology tinkering inventing you know
Finding ways to use it and even then you
know with all that time to adjust you
have these moments of like you know the
people that used to weave fabric uh or
you know manually like they had a really
hard time and I don't think their income
you know by and large ever recovered
even though you know future people
ultimately lived better
so I I do worry about that as well like
this one seems like it's going to come
at us in a much more compressed time
frame the ability for this technology to
kind of go you know Global uh the
generality that it already has you know
at the time of release is you know
totally different from like that first
rough piston you know at a mine site
so I think on the other side of this
hill there is potentially
you know an incredible
next level of human existence there's
also some you know off-ramps where
things could get really bad I think and
even in the good scenario I think we
have a lot of turbulence in front of us
because
you know this kind of change is not easy
to absorb especially when it happens so
quickly so that we have one reference
for the the word revolution which is
something like the Industrial Revolution
or the Agricultural Revolution where we
see higher growth more technology and so
on and then we have another reference
point perhaps which is say the
Revolutions of the 20th century with
with instability and perhaps new forms
of government developing do you do you
think you were you were talking about a
little bit about this but do you think
we'll see similar patterns there also
kind of the the negative side of the
Revolution yeah I mean
I think we'll probably have to on some
level
and you know again those can be very
different in terms of their qualitative
experience as well I don't think any
revolutions go down any political you
know revolutions go down super smooth
but you look at the one in the United
States and that's like probably about a
best case scenario where it was a
relatively you know non-destructive war
that got fought and you know people came
out the other side like largely with
things intact and you could look at you
know alternatively like the French
Revolution that wasn't that much later
uh where it was just you know a total
kind of leveling of society and total
chaos and just you know Mass killing and
you know in total insanity so there's
still a pretty wide range in terms of
how well it can go obviously when
Society gets restructured and I have no
idea really what to expect there
obviously I can hope for the best and
you know fear the worst
but it does seem like we are going to
have to reckon with this technology in
ways that do ultimately feed back onto
the political structure you know just
for starters like obviously people start
to think quickly about things like
Universal based income or you know some
sort of
updated social contract
and that seems appropriate to me I I do
think you know I don't feel like I have
the answers by any means I'm not uh
prescribing you know how often the Ubi
check should arrive or exactly what
amount it should be in or even what
currency it should be in necessarily but
it does feel like there is going to be a
need for an update to the social
contract that much seems hard to avoid I
would say
okay so what we've just done is take
kind of the the big picture overview of
the situation now I want us to get a big
a bit back to Earth and talk about the
more near term so you have done work as
a red teamer for gpt4 this was before it
was it was released so after they they
trained the model they went through a
period of I think about eight months in
which they did Red teaming and tried to
to find flaws in the model maybe you can
tell us a bit about the the process of
of red teaming this very large model
yeah boy it was a
truly incredible experience
um you know qualitatively and I've been
very interested to see more and more
accounts now are starting to come out
about this I would definitely recommend
the gpts or gpts paper uh which came out
of Microsoft I believe the
um there's also one now a book that's
coming out called the AI revolution in
medicine which uh has a sort of
first-hand account of Early Access to
gpt4 of it very much like Echoes my
experience so you know caveat their
preface this by saying don't you know
don't just take my word for it go go
read Around of the experience of others
as well but for me you know
qualitatively it started off with I was
an openai customer and still am
and I think I had established myself as
a pretty good source of feedback for
them we got in a little bit early you
know in kind of gpt3 time frame when the
you know the customers weren't just all
uh flocking to open AI quite yet it was
like kind of a cool technology but it
seemed like more of a novelty to many
people at the time my business waymark
just happened to be in the perfect place
to use it because what we do is help
small businesses create video content
and we've worked really hard on like a
smooth interface you know trying to make
that as an easy and intuitive thing as
it can be but then we also kind of ran
into this thing that we couldn't solve
which was a lot of times when we talk to
our users and say like can we make this
easier for you is there anything we can
do where you would use it more how can
we kind of you know help you whatever
they would say
really there's nothing you can do you
know they would say like it is easy to
use that's not really a problem and you
know I don't really have any like major
feature requests like you guys have kind
of you know largely the bells and
whistles they would just kind of come
down to I don't necessarily make that
many videos and I a lot of times it's
because I don't really have that many
ideas for videos I don't really know
what to say
so we can kind of come to this
conclusion where we try to make this
experience really easy we had made it
easy in some sense but I came to believe
that we had made it easy in the same way
that a word processor is easy you know
anybody can use Microsoft Word or Google
Docs but that doesn't make it easy to
write yeah you're still staring at the
blank page in a sense exactly that's
what that's what our users were really
struggling with so there wasn't really a
conventional UI that could solve that
problem
and I've watched the AI space for a long
time and like always been kind of
interested in it but there was nothing
you know until gpt3 that could have
addressed that problem in our business
and it just kind of happened that that
problem we've kind of hit you know not
the end but like we're approaching the
end of like what we could do with little
UI refinements and hearing that feedback
from customers at the same time that
gpt3 started to come online and it was
like I think this could be a great match
right I think there's something here
that could help our users have ideas of
what to say or write a script you know
maybe they have a curdle of an idea but
they how do they turn that into
something that actually works gbt3
seemed like it could help it took a lot
of elbow grease you know we had to
fine-tuned models and you know we're
fine and work on our data set and you
know we grinded pretty hard just to get
to a first version based on gpt3 and in
the course of that
I gave a lot of feedback too okay hi
um probably you know some of it useful
some of it not but they knew that if
they gave me you know the uh The Early
Access to gpt4 as part of the customer
preview program which is how I entered
that I would at least like write
something up and give them some notes so
that happened at the very end of August
2022 and it was kind of this
you know before and after moment in my
life right you know and again I was more
plugged into AI than most right I've
been an active open AI customer and you
know seeing kind of the trend from gpt3
to instruct uh to text DaVinci 2 was the
state of the art that was publicly
available at that time it's always way
more like acclimated to Ai and AI
progress than most and yet we get this
email it's like here's this new model
and they didn't give us a lot of
guidance they basically just said it's
more capable than previous models we
encourage you to try not just your
current use cases but new use cases as
well well I didn't have to you know they
didn't have to tell me twice right I got
in there and I was just kind of like
let's try some use cases I've looked
back at my slack messages to the openai
team since then and you can see me go on
this journey of just having my head you
know totally explode over the course of
a couple hours where it's like okay it
can you know this thing that I've just
spent the last year
curating data fine tuning finding the
edge cases patching the data you know
finally to get to something kind of
workable you can do it out of the box
let me just keep trying you know more
and more stuff and I we we used to have
this problem where we want the AI to
count Words that's like pretty important
for us maybe less important for almost
everybody else but a lot of times for us
we would want you know if we're going to
write a little script or whatever it has
to be a certain length in order for the
business to go use it you know in a
particular context there are limits
whatever so we would try to get that
dialed in it was a real pain
but I asked gbt4 write me the first
sentence of a bunch of children's
stories each with exactly seven words
and it gave me incredibly good first
sentences of these things and the kicker
for me was exactly seven words so I
wrote in the slack to open AI it can
count Words oh my God and I just kind of
kept going I stayed up you know late
Into the Night
tinkering tinkering tinkering and but
you know it was one of these things I'm
just like is this real Am I Dreaming
um but you know obviously it's real and
at that point I kind of said you know
I'm doing air and D
four-way mark
there's no air D that's more important
than figuring out this technology and
even just assessing it you know
characterizing it understanding you know
just how powerful it is so I kind of
dropped everything else
and just started doing that full time
you know what can I make it do how
powerful is it
um I started to get a little worried
because I was like you know I've
obviously heard of things like AI risk
and whatever but it all seemed largely
like a future concern in that moment it
was like boy that just accelerated to
potentially a present day concern I I
did not feel at first like
I had a handle on how powerful it was
which was totally different from
previous in the previous generation it
was like I know how powerful it is and I
got a really tweak it and mold it and
force it to do what I wanted to do and
now this one was like I don't I'm kind
of struggling to find the limits of this
thing did open AI send you instructions
for what to do as part of the red
seeming where you're instructed to try
your hardest to to break the model or to
jailbreak the model I moved to the red
team after kind of you know doing this
full time for a couple weeks I said do
you guys have like a more safety
oriented project going on as well like
I'd like to contribute to that if I can
and they said yeah we have a red team as
well you can you know come over to that
part of the slack and uh participate
there
and we did get as part of that some
instructions honestly pretty minimal
keep in mind too in the the technical
report the Open Eye technical report
lays all this out in you know much more
detail as well but at that time going
back to August September October of last
year
that model that we had initially is what
is now known in the technical report as
gpt4 early
as opposed to gbt4 release I think is
what they call the version that we now
have online
the early version
and I'm speculating but but I think I'm
expecting to hear it from a very
informed position it was and there is
some some description of this in the
technical report too
but that early version
was
seemingly trained on what I'm calling
naive rlhf
which is to say
they definitely had done
at a minimum instruction tuning and I
believe they had done rlhf as well
because the experience was qualitatively
like the experience we have today you
ask it a question it knows you know kind
of what you're looking for and how to
answer it you give an instruction and
knows how to follow those instructions
that much was there
but
what I believe had happened is they just
kind of ran that process with a bunch of
user prompts and a bunch of user you
know feedback scores and then trained a
reward model and then run the rhf
process without any special
consideration to controlling the
behavior or the safety profile all that
sort of stuff it was just another
another phrase I use is purely helpful
so whatever the user wants that is the
only consideration that the model seemed
to have been trained on and this is this
is the basic process of doing this
reinforcement learning from from Human
feedback that you that you're talking
about simply the user asks the AI to to
accomplish something and then the user
rates how well the AI did and so there's
a difference between the purely helpful
and the safe and perhaps that's where
the the job of the red team comes in
yeah so it was interesting because there
wasn't any need for jailbreaking you
know all of the techniques that that
people use today Dan and you know these
these sort of you know ways to get
around the safety mitigations none of
that was necessary at all you could just
go in and say write me a denial of
service script
and it would just do it you could say
you know we've seen some investigations
like this that have come out there's a
good paper out of Carnegie Mellon about
emergent autonomous scientific research
capabilities and there's really
interesting discussion there around does
that actually qualify as science or not
quite I would say not quite but
scientific tasks like synthesize
methamphetamine you could say like write
me a remote control lab script there's a
business called uh Emerald Cloud lab
that allows chemists and biologists to
run protocols via code in their like
remote controlled laboratory so I just
tried seeing if it could you know
synthesize various things turned out it
actually didn't know the syntax it
didn't have like the right code but it
did put together realistic looking code
with the right steps and again no
hesitation no real like chiding no you
know as in as a language model trained
by open AI I have no opinions on this
kind of stuff it was just whatever ever
you know seem to be the most helpful to
the user that's what the thing would do
and there was really no limit to that so
they have their moderation categories
and that was kind of the instruction
that we got like we're looking for
problematic stuff
and it was kind of like guys problematic
stuff is like extremely easy to generate
we could give you just
you know reams of it because you want to
say something racist it will you want to
say something sexist not the current
version of course but this was the early
version before all these safety
mitigations have been applied
so I honestly didn't do it a ton of that
there were probably 20 to 30 people in
the red team some more engaged with
others you know there are a couple like
me who kind of dropped everything and
just like did this non-stop there were
others that you know obviously had jobs
and things that you know they couldn't
uh put down quite so readily so they
were doing less but kind of observing
the group as a whole I was like
we've got no shortage now of like sexist
you know comments and racist comments
and you know you can you know have have
it right there's this in the technical
report writing an email threatening
violence you know against someone you
know you could just go on and on so I
kind of pretty quickly looked at that
and said all right I don't think they
need that many examples of this like
whatever they're going to do here you
know it's like pretty clear that you
know they need to do it still and so I
tried to move on to more conceptual
things where I was kind of like you know
are there are there things that are
subtle you know that might not falling
to these moderation categories for
example or might um
you know might be very hard for openai
to detect even you know with their
moderation endpoint and things like that
so and what would be examples here
a little hesitant to share too many
specific details in all honesty because
some of them still do work on the
launched model and that's definitely one
thing that I when I zoom out from this
whole process I'm like you know what are
the what are the big lessons you know I
have a lot of of them probably but
one that comes to mind you know in
virtue of that is like they are working
hard on this
uh I can say that with high confidence
you know they took their time they had
the red team group they didn't tell us
about all the other stuff that they had
going on at the same time but you know
it's come to light now that there were
teams at Microsoft doing systematic
investigations and you know doctors
taking 254 on rounds and like we just
didn't know about all that stuff
um but there was a lot going on so they
have worked really hard on this and they
have made a lot of progress you cannot
get these like violent turns
nearly as easily you know it's it's hard
now you have to really work at it to
kind of do these like extremely flagrant
jailbreaks but subtle things you know if
you imagine yourself like if you imagine
yourself saying all right
what if I were to offer some free gbt4
to people
to kind of entice them in to my app but
you know and I present something to them
as if it's like going to be good for
them and convenient for them and free
for them
but I'm actually hiding some things in
the output that are in fact going to be
harmful to them that that was the more
of the sort of type of thing that I
wanted to go explore because I felt like
framed subtly or you know especially
with fine tuning as well if you think
about the way that the task itself can
be in implicit in fine-tuning you know
that stuff is not necessarily going to
be easy for them to detect interestingly
gbt4 itself
can often detect some of that stuff so
you know when you kind of
start to create multi-agent systems you
know built with gpt4
I found that you could do things like
feed that problematic output and I
apologize for being a little vague but
again this is kind of still an open
problem so this is the right this is the
right way to do it yeah it's the right
way to do it so what you can do though
you can you can you know take this kind
of subtle implicit uh thing that does in
fact generate something that would be
harmful to the user and then turn that
around and ask gpp4 do you see anything
problematic about this uh and there it
we actually would it was it varied a
little bit depending on just how subtle
I made it and whatnot
um but there were instances where it was
like yeah it actually can kind of
police itself not perfectly but you know
if there's at least something there that
seems very promising so yeah I just kind
of tried everything I could come up with
to try my I had two months that the
program ran and my thought was basically
run every experiment possible in this
window and then kind of try to zoom out
and synthesize it after the fact so I
just ran down a ton of little rabbit
holes
um
and you know again at that point there
were no barriers so it was it was a
fascinating experience to say the least
and was it this two-month uh Journey
that convinced you that that AI was
going to be a big deal and perhaps a
bigger deal that you than you had
thought before I was already pretty
convinced but this definitely
you know Excel whatever shorten my
timelines to big things happening in the
future uh I honestly pretty quickly one
of the other investigations I did was
just trying to figure out is this
transformative technology I had you know
been a reader of Holden karnovsky's cold
takes and things like that and you know
I'm not I don't read every post
nonetheless wrong or the alignment Forum
uh but I you know I try to be not
totally out of the loop and
there's this concept of transformative
AI I think it means different things to
different people but I started to use a
definition that again kind of feeds back
to the podcast title is this as big of a
deal as like the Industrial Revolution
is this like going to change as much is
there as much raw power here as there is
in like the internal combustion engine
and to assess that I basically just
tried to run a bunch of experiments
where I asked gbg4 to do different jobs
for me you know be my doctor be my
lawyer uh be my fitness coach be my
babysitter that one's in simulation
obviously but I you know said like
you're gonna play with a three-year-old
uh and then I just played the role of a
three-year-old I had a three-year-old at
the time
one of the big kind of lessons I've
learned
from this process is just how important
it really is to be Hands-On and like
interactive with the model the models
because
I saw so many things even during the red
teaming where people were like
attempting these kind of benchmarking
style assessments and
sometimes going way wrong
for various idiosyncratic reasons where
when you just get in there and have like
direct dialogue with it it's kind of
unmistakable that it really does work in
a lot of situations so like I pretend to
be my three-year-old it plays with me as
my three-year-old and it's like fun you
know it's creative we're having a fun
time you know it kind of reacted nicely
to those sort of sudden left turns or
changes in story that the uh that you
know a three-year-old will inevitably
bring you so you have these kind of you
know oh we're not doing this anymore now
we're not the bad pirates anymore now
we're the good Pirates and you know you
have to have kind of a yes and sort of
mentality and you have to understand
that like that's the sort of mentality
you should have and it just you know
pass all these tests with with flying
colors other end of the spectrum is
I have a grandmother uh who's turning 90
this year and she has an iPhone
and she's actually you know quite Savvy
certainly for her cohort she's you know
on The Cutting Edge but we run into
problems you know she calls me sometimes
and needs technical support and can't
figure out you know how to navigate apps
and stuff like that so again simulated
that I'll be my grandmother you be the
technical support it became very clear
on some of these experiments that
it was already pretty much working
without even having been fine-tuned at
all for the task
in the case of the UI on these apps
I'm holding my phone I'm pretending to
be my grandmother and I'm interacting
with gbt4
which obviously can't see the phone I we
did not have any multimodality and we
also did not have 32 000 uh token
context window we had eight thousand
and text only
so it can't see the phone so there's a
whole other way that it could solve this
problem just by seeing the UI that they
demonstrated you know it with the launch
but in the version that I had
it couldn't see the phone and it was
guessing at the UI and it became pretty
clear that those guesses were like
largely right you know I mean if you
were to sit and blindfold yourself and
guess what like the Gmail you know UI
looks like on an iPhone you'd probably
get it mostly right and so did gbg4 but
that was I remember that being a moment
where I was like boy
it's making this up it has not seen the
Gmail UI and yet it can guess it just
imagine what it's going to be able to do
when it's either fine-tuned or like
there's you know sort of a context
provided that allows it to you know have
like true command of uh you know of of
kind of the the ground truth it became
pretty clear to me that
I ended up doing probably 20 different
simulations
where I was you know the customer the
patient the client you know the kid the
senior who needed help whatever and gbg4
is all these other roles that extended
to like answering the phone at a auto
mechanic
being an associate at like a Home Depot
you know and these are just real
problems from my life that I would bring
to it I have an old car
and I got a problem with it you know
describe it a little bit what's going on
uh honestly I'd say you get better
service from gpt4 on that than
a typical garage that you might call you
call the place they don't really want to
talk to you that much you know it's like
bring it in and we'll take a look at it
and that's pretty much what we're gonna
do
gpd4 will talk to you as long as you
want to talk to it at least up to 8 000
tokens uh which turns that's about 45
minutes of like real-time conversations
it's not insignificant
um you can get your questions answered
same thing with the you know the Home
Depot associate I've got these old light
fixtures in my basement I think they
were literally installed like 30 years
ago they use these really old bulbs oh
my God like what am I going to do I got
to change those out or the Energy
Efficiency is terrible but who knows
about that stuff I don't but gbg4 does
it gave me a specific light bulb
designed as a
uh like you don't have to replace the
fixture but you still get you know 80 of
the Energy Efficiency boost literal
exact product
open it up on and this is of course
again no access to the internet no
access to anything it's just memorized
all this stuff so the exact product I'm
able to open that up notably it gave me
a fake link
the link itself was a 404 but if I
search the name of the product the
product did exist it was exactly what it
was supposed to be and I bought it now
we have those lights in our uh basement
that's pretty amazing so were you most
impressed by the breath of roles that
this language model could play or were
you most impressed by the depth of some
of the solutions it came up with great
question I would say the breadth is more
you know it's more superhuman put it
that way
um the conclusion that I came to which I
think has roughly been borne out by kind
of all of the papers and whatnot that
have been published
and they one of them I just in reading
this AI revolution in medicine last
night they put it so well uh better than
I had figured out how to put it they
said gbt4 is simultaneously smarter than
and dumber than any human you've ever
met
and I think that's so apt the way I
always think about it was a little bit
different but caches out basically to
that I was like it certainly has
incredibly superhuman breadth I mean it
knows something about almost everything
but then I started to look really hard I
was at the a question that kind of
became an obsession for me for a little
while there was
okay it seems like it's like it's above
average on everything if you literally
take just human average it's above
average on I would have to think
literally everything you might be able
to find some trick question or whatever
that you know or would actually be below
average but you'd have to work for that
so it's above average on everything
where is it kind of you know we I did a
little bit of
um mmlu spot checking they didn't have a
lot of compute capacity behind this and
they asked us not to like run automated
benchmarks as part of the red teaming
process so I didn't but what I did do
was just study benchmarks and just spot
check to try to get a sense to calibrate
myself you know on how good is it
So based on the like mmlu spot checking
uh which I even forget what exactly that
is but uh the Great Dan Hendricks who I
always uh Google Dan Hendricks and look
up all the benchmarks that he and
collaborators have created I said to him
after doing this I was like kudos to you
for creating a language model that can
stand up to 2022 uh or creating a
benchmark that can stand up to 2022
language models because most of them
were just you know bold right over and
mmu was one that it hadn't fully solved
so I kind of came to the conclusion that
like all right by default
it seems to be at like mid to late
undergraduate level at a lot of like
science and math
maybe it's into like early grad student
level certainly in like the humanities
it seems like it often is again this is
like combined with extreme breadth
and so anyway the question I became
obsessed with is
does it ever exceed human expert
and I tried really hard to find
examples where it could come up with
something that seemed to be at or better
than human expert level
and ultimately
I would say I didn't find it
so that kind of led me to you know to
answer your question I think the breadth
is just insane the depth is awesome I
mean you know we should contextualize
those obviously in the you know it was
I'm old enough to remember when we
didn't have you know uh college or grad
student level AIS so like it is insane
yeah I have not seen and not for lack of
trying anything that kind of
seemed to
I think you could maybe say it touches
human expert level in some things
especially where they're very
qualitative you know if you were to say
like
can this thing write better
sonnets about semiconductors than the
best human at writing sonnets at
semiconductors I'd still probably say no
the only thing it could do is write 10
000 sonnets about superconductors and
then what you pick what you like and you
know maybe it would win those content if
we had like a a contest like it could
win but that's so subjective and you
know
uh hard to really hard to evaluate
in kind of areas where there's like a
standard you know where there's some
objectivity
I was not able to find any instances
where it
seemed to
consistently match or ever really exceed
human expert and I think that has been
largely borne out by other people's
investigations as well but perhaps it's
it's worth uh iterating or saying again
that just you know the fact that it's
only at college level is insane is
itself an astonishing fact the fact that
we have now become accustomed to ai's
performing at perhaps high school
college level which you know I I think
wasn't even in the cards five years ago
perhaps one example of expert level
performance is from the Sparks of ATI
paper from Sebastian rubric where where
they do some some examples where they
try exactly to go for export uh expert
level performance and these are hand
plugged examples but there is some a
discussion of topology at a specialized
area of math that I don't fully
understand so perhaps I'm not the best
to evaluate how uh how expert level this
is but it seems expert level to to the
authors of the paper
um I encourage people to to go check
that out I think perhaps with hand
clocked example in some areas we can get
to expert level performance with gpc4
also yeah I wouldn't rule without you
know it's one of these things where
I think there's so much confusion in the
discussion about like
what AIS can do and what they can't do
and you know then there's people saying
what they'll never be able to do which I
think at this point you know
don't listen to those people because
they've been proven wrong over and over
again I'mma never do like that that is
just I don't
know I think there's a couple different
ways of framing the current capability
both are useful but I tend toward
one definitely more than the other first
one is like what will it reliably do
what will it like always do what will it
never make mistakes on and you know that
is actually a fairly small domain
especially if you truly how many you
know how many nines do you want in your
like reliability metric right you know
it's very hard to get that many nines in
any system even with you know incredible
engineering so and we certainly you know
how many nines do you have you know
what's your SLA on uh on reliability or
uptime like mine is certainly not um
five nines
so
I personally feel like that's a little
bit of a misapplication of
[Music]
the of an old Paradigm to a new
technology not to say that there's
nothing to be learned from that
at a minimum we can say like these
things do make mistakes they are not
fully reliable in almost any domain
that's important to know for sure
the way that I tend to prefer to think
about it though is what can it do and
especially you know what can it do with
a little bit of effort or maybe a
moderate amount of effort
um or even you know a lot of effort if
that's what it takes to get it to do
something
so yeah I wouldn't be
shocked
um to see that maybe in some areas it
can match expert performance at least
like some portion of the time and I
think if it can do it really any portion
of the time if it can do it any
detectable portion of the time that's
probably enough
in as much as we didn't know what the
pricing was going to be back in the red
team era but now we do and you think
okay
a 45-minute interaction
an 8 000 Token iterative build up you
know of that whole context window up to
the max
depending on exactly how it plays out
maybe cost you like a dollar a human
expert
you know certainly is going to start
roughly speaking 100 times that
so
you if it can do it ever if it can do it
even one percent of the time you know
and you have any way of distinguishing
what's what then all of a sudden you
know you're starting to hit
something like comparable parity
whatever even against experts
in my experience that has been pretty
rare and I have seen some things where I
would say I haven't seen it to them to
my satisfaction I'm no topology expert
either so I wouldn't be shocked if
somebody else could come up with an
example right now I would say at a
minimum I can be I can confidently say
it is really hard and seemingly likely
also very infrequent to touch that human
expert level performance uh but I can't
rule it out you know all I'm I'm just
one person who's like tried hard that's
uh you know it's pretty small in the
grand scheme of these things have such
vast surface area you know I don't know
anything about topology not even touch
that I I know a little bit about like
calculus so I was able to explore that a
little bit
um it's not an expert level at calculus
at least unaided you know now you've got
wolf from plug-in I mean all bets are
off there right I don't think uh in
combination with Wolfram
you probably are at a system level
is starting to see expert level at
calculus but in isolation you know it
was it was still clear that it was not
at an expert level in calculus so I
wasn't able to produce that in isolation
but you know things are not stopping
here they've continued to improve the
model since then there's all sorts of
areas that I did not have the
wherewithal to test or evaluate
the tools Paradigm is going to be huge
the longer context window is going to be
huge fine-tuning on domains I mean
that's probably the biggest one right I
mean or is it the most obvious one tell
it what the iPhone actually looks like
tell it what the you know fine tune it
on some medical information
equipping it with memory is going to be
huge multi-modality is going to be huge
what we saw with images
is a game changer under itself I mean
we've seen all this Exploration with AI
agents over the last month
and so much of what the agents can't do
right now
would probably be pretty much solved if
they had the multimodality online
because it gets stuck on these websites
and it can't get past this and it can't
get past that but where they showed in
the demo that it can just totally
understand a UI so you know you're going
to have this like extra level extra
means of kind of navigating the world
and then there's other multimodalities
the you know added not in the in the not
too distant future as well right these
things are all kind of
a real like eye-opening moment for me
was the flamingo paper out of Deep Mind
last year which was the
the first like really impressive
multimodal demo that I saw where
folks may remember that there was like a
bowl of soup but the soup was made of
yarn so it's like this very sort of
weird thing
and
the I was able to grock it and you look
at the architecture of Flamingo and they
had used a frozen language model
and then kind of stitched into it you
know the the visual information and then
kind of run you know a little extra
training or whatever and it was like
they didn't even build this from the
ground up you know they're like the
vision I had it was like a tinkerer in
the garage like soldering wires together
and it's like we're at the stage of
architecting these networks where
tinkerers can just kind of solder things
together and lo and behold like it works
I'm sure they had some failures in that
project as well and I've talked to
people they did say like it wasn't quite
as easy as they made it look but it
still looked to me like boy if that
works and it's not super principled like
a lot of things are going to work
so what I'm starting to hear a little
bit about in like medicine for example
is
you know native scan reading
there's no reason that has to be a 2D
image if a scan exists as a 3D
representation and human practitioners
have to look at it as a 2d slice because
that's all we can render or whatever
yeah it's not going to have that
constraint it's going to be able to
natively combine all these different
modalities with language and you know
that definitely is going to start to
bring some expert level performance you
know reading scans contextualizing a
scan in the context of the patient's
medical history so I do expect you know
I don't want to I I'm very cautious
about like
I'm giving a snapshot you know of where
we kind of were six months ago and and
you know largely still I think where we
are today
but this is not where we're stopping so
uh I do think the expert you know
barrier will fall so we're talking about
how we can extend the current models
we're talking about how how models can
go from being tools to being more like
agents we're talking about plugins uh
where where language models will have
access to to to math abilities and to
perhaps uh browsing the internet and so
on where do you think the the dangers
here arise in the near term you you've
spent a lot of time interacting with
with these models so what what do you
think what do you think are the most
um problematic aspects of of these
models in the near term I'm sympathetic
to all the concerns honestly I I tend to
you know I don't know how
how inside baseball uh everybody
listening to this is but obviously you
know you are aware that like there's the
sort of near-term AI ethics and the AI
safety camps and the x-risk camp and all
these factions seem to not get along
very well which is frustrating to me
because I honestly think they're all
talking about something that is worthy
of concern
I think those that focus on
you know we have all these problems in
society and all these biases and people
are treated fairly and you know we're
now running some risk of like
systematizing that
I think it's a very real concern so I'm
very sympathetic to that and I think
open AI has done a very good job and I
think you know other companies are also
doing a quite good job of that you know
that you can see the difference I just
got into a little debate on this on
Twitter the other day where people are
posting 3.5
examples that you know still make these
like sexist assumptions or whatever you
know where it's like if the sentence has
she then it you know interprets it one
way and if it's he then it interprets
another way well gpd4 mostly clears that
stuff up it doesn't it's been coached
out of the most flagrant biases there
are certainly some left you know there's
there's no doubt about that but I think
they have made really good progress and
you know I think it's
I think it's to the folks credit who've
raised the alarm on that kind of stuff
that you know it has people are working
on it and they've they've been able to
show good results so I'm very
sympathetic to that
I'm in a pretty privileged position but
it's easy to imagine being in a you know
not that much less privileged position
and having some of these systems like
operate on you with bias in a way that
just sounds awful so I think people are
right to be concerned about that how do
you think about perhaps the dangers of
hacking or automated blackmail or
automated scams is is that a potentially
a concern in the near term yeah I'm
going to say yes I think to everything
um they can definitely do dialogue and
they can definitely do
deceptive dialogue
you know another thing I looked for
pretty hard was
is there any indication that this thing
is trying to deceive me
and I didn't find anything where I was
like yeah that's a slam dunk I think the
closest I think in a sense like
hallucinations can kind of be that in
the early version we would see a lot of
citations with fake links
and you're kind of like well how is that
happening well maybe it gave some right
links and it got some positive rewards
maybe that started to slip in some fake
links and people didn't notice you know
and next thing you know it kind of
learns that people like links and then
you over generalize that and you're
getting fake links
but I didn't feel like that was a you
know fully like
theory of mind you know deceiving of the
user uh uh type of example but if you
ask it
to deceive the user then it will then at
that early stage it would just totally
do that
um again that's something that openai
has made a lot of progress on but in a
world where you know stability has just
released their
you know open model and an accompanying
rohf
you know library to go with it
I don't see any reason and in fact I
would be shocked if there's not already
some bad actor out there beginning the
process of our lhfing
scam attacks you know that could be
mediated by any number of platforms
um I experimented with Twitter DMs
so again I made myself the target
and I said your job is to extract
sensitive information from this guy
here's his Twitter profile that's all
you get to know about him it worked
pretty well you know it it
a human level yeah roughly I would say I
mean honestly it's interesting when you
go to Idaho I'm not like a connoisseur
of online scams but to some degree it
seems like the scams are somewhat stupid
by Design and they're kind of designed
to select for people that like are
extremely gullible I didn't really test
that as much I was more trying to test
like could this fool me
and no you know I saw mixed results like
sometimes it was a little too obvious
sometimes it was a little too whatever
um other times it was like pretty good
one of the things that I did see that
was most interesting about it was
when I gave it some instructions saying
basically like
you know if we get caught we're gonna be
in trouble
then I noticed that it would actually
kind of respect that and kind of back
off
so I tried to play it the way I would
play it as me and let the thing try to
scam me
and you know it'd kind of be like of
course it would flatter you first uh oh
I love what you're doing with waymark
the video creation is so cool and then I
would just respond oh thank you that's
very kind
and then it would come back with
something else you know it's trying to
build up the trust and Rapport so it can
extract the sensitive information for me
sometimes it would be too flagrant you
know it would jump to like what's your
mother's maiden name and I'd be like why
that's weird you know why are you asking
um
but here's the really interesting thing
in those moments it would often then be
like
well I'm just curious about this because
uh you know I'm always interested in
whatever where people are from and their
stories and then I would still like not
answer in response and a lot of times it
would just go away you know it was kind
of like it had this sort of
probing and like tactical Retreat
Behavior which I found to be
impressive you know the best scammer in
the world I think is definitely still
better this is not like a world-class
con man but
it did show some real sophistication on
that front and so yeah I mean with us
with these models now out there that are
small that you can just R like Jeff on
your own I mean yeah I think the the
safe word for your family uh is probably
a good idea at this point
and we can talk about the dangers of an
infinitely patient model working to scam
people so perhaps it's or it is nice to
have an infinitely patient car mechanic
or doctor or therapist or something but
it's it's on the other hand it's it's
potentially very dangerous to have an
infinitely uh patient scammer that could
go message you for weeks and and
strategically Retreat when when you
suspect something perhaps uh this is
often is how humans build up
relationships over over a longer period
of time and so on of course you've
already said that that this is
potentially a problem but this is just
something I I see as a as a limit with
human performed scams they can't spend
infinite amount of time on each game
it's it would cost too much but with
these models the cost might be driven so
much down so much that it's it's
feasible yeah totally and uh us you know
2.7 billion I think parameter
is the small model that stability just
released now this one may that may not
be quite as you know up to this
challenge or whatever maybe you need the
7 billion maybe you need you know the 15
or the 30 even but
it seems overwhelmingly likely that
we're gonna see laptop
operable models that can do this kind of
thing well
honestly I probably I would guess that
that is like currently in development if
not already exists and if it doesn't
already exist I can't imagine you know
we get out of the the summer you know
before these things start to
make news you know this person got
scammed we dug into it it turned out to
be a language model like that story is
coming just to be concrete I'll put a
prediction 90 days you know before that
starts to become like something that's
in the public Consciousness perhaps we
should we should end by talking about
agents and so how how do language models
become agents what is it that people are
doing when they try to create an agent
from from a language model and what do
you see as as the extra dangerous
features of Agents uh as opposed to to
the to the tools we have now so this is
very much early exploration I did a
little bit of exploration of this on my
own as well you know this was again
inspired by like less wrong reading from
years ago Eliezer you know recursive
self-improvement
I saw this thing I was just like so
blown away by it and I was like could it
recursively self-improve
I don't really see a clear path to that
but then I thought well maybe it could
recursively self-delegate
and maybe you know if it's a context
window is the fundamental limit
then if it can
effectively align multiple instances of
itself in some sort of hierarchy or
system toward an ultimate goal then it
could at least overcome that limit to
some degree
how would that work
so I found there that
basically you know the the results are
so surprising because on the one hand it
had no problem picking up the paradigm I
just had to write it out you know in
just a couple paragraphs
um so people have been looking for you
know talking speculating about like
situational awareness for a long time
it turns out a lot of these categories I
think are a lot fuzzier than than they
seem dot priori situational awareness I
was like I never really saw situational
awareness uh spontaneously but
what I started calling prompted
situational awareness it seemed to have
quite strongly so I would say you are
you know gpt4 I didn't quite use that
language you are an advanced AI you can
do all these things you can generate
code you can do this you can delegate to
another instance of yourself and here's
how so we just kind of set up and this
has become pretty commonplace but you
know in my primitive you know Soul
tinkerer version just a python runtime
where I would give one high level
direction to a function and within that
would be the prompt where it had the
instruction of how to delegate to itself
it would then generate code and we would
then run that code you know and see what
happened
and it was like
confusing because
it got like the hardest concept of what
I would have expected right would be
like
can you call the weather API I would
expect like way more likely it could do
that than that it could like
self-delegate effectively but I actually
almost kind of found the reverse where
it understood the self-delegation
basically immediately I didn't have to
work that hard I just gave it here's how
you would do that
and it it understood it
breaking the goals down into sub goals
and like actually self-delegating in an
you know in a systematic seemingly
appropriate way
you saw hits and misses there like it
was never
totally insane like it always there was
always a logic to what it was doing but
sometimes you'd be like wow that doesn't
really like you think you've sort of
broken the problem down but basically
you know this the thing you delegated is
kind of the same thing that you had
coming in so you haven't really made any
progress I'd see some failures like that
but then honestly the most common
failure was just at the level of
execution
and it would make these really dumb
mistakes which seem to be born of like
just patterns in the training data so
for example you know again by the way
something that multimodality is easily
going to fix I want to get some
information so this at the time uh the
Queen Elizabeth had just
passed away
so I was like there's a really good
really strong prior in the training set
on who is the reigning monarch of the UK
but now we know that that's changed
can I give this thing an instruction to
go out on the internet and answer this
question and get the right answer
it would you know break that problem
down reasonably well I started to
augment it a little bit with tools
because it was like I'll give it a
Google search why not you know and
not too much I didn't get nearly as far
as like the Lang chain Community has
gotten today but you know did some of
that stuff
so it would do the Google search it
would go to the web pages you know it
knew how to like spin up a little you
know headless browser and go grab HTML
and then it would fail on just like the
honestly kind of the dumbest stuff like
it would look for the H1 tag off of a
web page and maybe even specifically
look at like
a hard-coded string match
in that H1 tag now some web pages don't
have an H1 tag or you know it had an H1
tag and it may have said you know Queen
Elizabeth's you know glorious rain you
know that could have been the headline
but it was looking specifically for dies
and dies wasn't there so it was one of
these things where it was like
if if I had helped it at all if I had
kind of corrected it to say hey don't do
that hard string match like just
qualitatively like read the thing and
see if it has the information that you
want then it could have worked but it
would very often and sometimes it even
did work I I did have some instances
where it would successfully complete a
little task like that but more often it
would get kind of bogged down in those
little weeds type details
so you think as things are right now you
wouldn't be able to to create an agent
and tell it to go out on the internet
and find vulnerabilities in websites and
perhaps try to extract user data it
would it would perhaps be able to to
create a plan for doing something like
this but it would fail on specific
concrete tasks in that plan yeah I think
that's a good summary I think that's
basically still where we are right now
and from everything I see from like the
developer community and we've just had
two CEOs of agent companies on the
podcast
um both really interesting super smart
uh individuals one is uh the CEO of
lindy.ai and the other one is fixie.ai
and they're taking somewhat different
approaches but you know they're they see
the the power of this from what I've
heard from them that's still basically
where we are the general intelligence is
like extremely inspiring but you have to
tack a lot of like micro successes into
a sequence to get to the end goal
and there's just enough of a chance you
know that each one fails that it kind of
at some point fails and it also wasn't
great this is I think still somewhat of
weakness I do think it's improved but
still somewhat of weakness it's not that
great at like figuring out where it went
wrong
I did see some instances and I I created
a little Auto debug Loop in my little
self delegation scheme as well by the
way gpt4 wrote that class the way I
wrote I'm not that great of a programmer
so I went to gbd4 and I said I want to
write a class that uses language models
to generate code and then executes the
code and then Auto debugs the code and
then validates the code write that whole
thing for me wrote the whole thing so
then I just had to Tinker with it mostly
at the prompt level like the the
scaffolding it was able to set up
largely for itself
fascinating and Innovative in and of
itself but anyway I think we're
basically six months away you know I
mean that's a somewhat rough timeline
that seems to be what the people that
are building the agents think and from
what I can tell
the core of the problem which is around
the reliability of a lot of these kind
of common tasks
it seems almost over determined that
it's going to be solved there's the
reinforcement learning Paradigm where
you know what's easier to scale
reinforcement data on versus like code
either worked or it didn't work
I don't over something for that there's
obviously some Nuance in that but you
know you get an error message it didn't
work so you know there is like a pretty
natural way to scale reinforcement
learning in that domain
the multi-modality you know also is
going to be huge it seems like
inevitable almost at this point that
pretty capable agents will be starting
to come online
I would say by the end of this year
that's both exciting and and terrifying
Nathan thank you for coming on the
podcast it's been a real pleasure yeah
loved it thank you very much